uh i ran to a church
and i snuck into the church and i uh
got a bible out of the church and then i
gave it to someone um on the street and
then i ran back is that cool
end time give it up for chrissy and john
they just went on a date together yeah
what did you think about
what did you think about this date
um it was interesting she was she was
leading did you feel that she was
leaning leading leading yeah absolutely
no i was following yeah
definitely did that do you uh do you
like those kind of relationships where
the woman is wearing the pants
um
kind of
i just kind of like to be told what to
do sometimes
yeah you got a real uh
donald trump tell me where to when to
invade the capital kind of lives yeah
he has bottom vibes straight bottom
um so
uh christie you said that you stole a
bible from a church and gave it to
someone else yeah do you often like to
admit to crimes on dates
uh yeah i just try to like
i just try to like distract them from
like anything else that's going on
so you don't want them to realize that
you're on a date with them yeah i don't
want them to like i want to just throw
things at them and they're just like
trying to figure out what's going on the
whole time
nice confuse your opponent this is
sun tzu's art of getting laid yeah
overwhelmed them that was fast though
that was yeah it was it was the right
amount of time for me
yeah
molly what did you think about this
wonderful couple they were just on a
date they were vibing i thought it was a
good date i like the date a lot i like
that christy lead i
you're a sub for sure
for sure
yeah like you're waiting for her to tell
you where you can come and when right
yeah why not yeah
yeah wondering about your nipples were
you excited that she asked about them
like are you into nipple play
uh no
he's not i don't know i don't really
have fantasize about nipples
i mean i know
i like girl nipples but i don't really
tend to look at my nipples me too bro
what's the difference girl nipples um
they're not mine i guess that well then
i could look at a guy but i didn't see
yours are they hairy no i don't i'm not
a very hairy person no okay the size on
the face
that's a good yeah from the neck down
you're like a dolphin
you got all your hair up top i feel like
you might shed a lot onto your nipples
though from all the hair
is that true i don't know not really i
don't know i don't shed i'm not a dog
falling onto the nipple like a waterfall
yeah yeah that's a very uh even exchange
you know christy led and uh it seems
like the kind of relationship where it's
like who's pulling who's ponytail
[Laughter]
you guys are both
yanking each other's hair you know yeah
i would yeah i wonder if we should get
it like i want to do a dominant person
on here one time at some point but would
you guys go on a run together since you
both like to run how fast can you run
around like a nine minute mile oh [ __ ]
that's not that i could slow down it's
not that fast no but well i run like 10
miles a day oh you're a you're a long
distance runner
no no not at all
is that your job
running away from the delivery nipple
fetish then what are you running away
from
not running from anything uh so running
to get away from
i don't know i'm trying to be healthy
it's very uh misleading because you're
very hairy so it might look like you're
not that athletic but you actually seem
pretty you're wearing an under armour
hat
you like to keep hammering
i do like to keep hammering like
campaigns yes i do okay have you thought
about taking off the beer so you'd be
like more aerodynamic for the runs
no i've never really thought of that
it's probably i guess it could work
swimmers do it but i'm on air so it's
different he's an air runner
well i'm on land a land runner
man what a wonderful land creature we
have tonight
uh christy uh what is your experience on
land or sea do you uh do you like to go
swimming for cardio or you're mostly a
land-based creature last time i went
swimming i had a yeast infection whoa
nice and there was a red flag that rose
above the water and i noticed it's
actually the sharks had a lifeguard they
were warning each other not to bite me
what the [ __ ] is going on we should say
that christie is actually a comedian and
sometimes she uh inserts puns and uh
weird uh improv games into dates yeah
have you ever actually asked a date can
i see your nipples on a date like is
that a thing you do in a restaurant yeah
hey wow that's not normal um
you uh
yeah that's awesome so what what what
responses do you get when you ask people
to see their nipples are they usually
for it
um
yeah i just want to see right away what
kind of fitness level i'm dealing with
you know so it's like looking into a
horse's mouth you look at a man's
nipples yeah like people try to cover up
their problem areas and i just want to
see them so i can you know time
management that's my resolution this
year
i think that's a good idea i feel like
you're like weeding out the week yeah
like if you're too scared to show me
your nipple are you ever gonna open up
truly
yeah
i think you're on to something christy
you should put that in your rider when
you uh tour as a comedian
it's like i need to see your nipples a
nipple on a plate so that you know what
kind of quality venue you're at it's
like the green m m's thing i don't know
if you guys know that about writers but
dude a writer is like a plate that you
get in in the green room do you guys
know it's like a it's like a piece of
paper that you hand to people oh my god
get me out of here i don't know anything
she doesn't know anything no a writer a
writer is like what you order for
to be served to you it could be anything
not just food anything that you want in
the room a writer is what uh john does
when he has sex is he uh he's a writer
she's a sub
john how do you feel about chrissy
admitting to not knowing a lot
um
very confusing
have you ever met anyone that
asked to see your nipple on a date no
this is the first time that's ever
happened to me
you seem very nervous you're sweating a
lot are you excited nervous or are you
like
like what's the vibe how are you just
kind of nervous i would say
is it me or is it christy or is it hans
i think a little bit of everything
uh
not necessarily you're going to have a
form here
i believe that you had to get in
yourself yeah for a guy that runs i
think your cardio would be better
she would think instead of going on a
run just go on a date with christy and
you don't have to go on a run you'll get
all the cardio you need
i'll throw things at you
okay i could dodge
so uh anyone else want to sign up
we need more women we need ladies you
just pull people up if you guys want to
come up you're just too scared to sign
up right so we're gonna literally we're
gonna go into the audience and start
picking people out it's gonna be like uh
russell brand during his special every
girl here is hot come on
come up here no reason to be insecure
you can wear a mask like that one lady
is doing
how does it feel to be the only liberal
in texas
let's all see your vax card so that we
can photocopy it later we can make
copies of it
uh so are you vaxxed john no i'm not
whoa what a surprise
the guy with the under armour head and
unkempt facial hair isn't vexed
but he's running so i think he's fine
like he has really good lung capacity
he's heaving and hoeing all throughout
the city just taking a sampling of the
air hopefully there's not a coronavirus
in it
uh chrissy what is your vaccination
status
zero
oh you guys have so much in common
yeah
dude i have a question for you though
like oh okay koreans don't get body odor
you don't have body odor like it's
genetic you literally do not create
bodies you don't have a certain type of
body odor oh there's different ways that
we smell
oh really yeah you gotta you gotta get
to know a korean to really understand i
was just wondering if you thought that
like if you if
you have no body at her and like if you
see me and i have all this like
you know i have to wear deodorant like
if do you think that we're gross like
white people are gross oh yeah i do have
a deep-seated hatred for the white race
yeah
no i think
nice the white girls agree
the two white women are on board with
the racism
like if you smelled my armpits without
deodorant you'd be like jesus christ
cause your whole race doesn't even
create that smell
so then you smell it on me and you're
like wow like what an i mean i grew up
with a lot of white people yeah that's
why english is so good
i'm one of you i
i think i'm white i'm like a dog that
grew up with cats but you're like a
clean you're a clean whitey
i'm a clean white yeah i have the eyes
of an asian and the uh
bloodthirsty capitalism of an american
oh [ __ ] anyways so uh what do you think
about uh the whole you know texas versus
california everyone's moving here how
long have you have you lived here so i
don't live here um i lived in new york i
been in charleston south carolina for
the last nine months but i'm looking to
move here in march did you run here i
did not i flew a plane well i didn't fly
the plane here i was on a plane i
believe you could
so i do wouldn't want to let uh run like
from one end to the country to the other
in like the next couple years that's my
goal you already look like forrest gump
when he already did that that's kind of
that's what i'm going for you know
yeah for you it'd be the other way
around you slowly start shaving and you
get even more clean cut there it'll
eventually come the hair would disappear
as you the air flows through it
uh so what do you guys uh think about
texas you uh you you want to move here
yeah and what for the comedy or um
yes the comedy so
in new york i used i was a big guy like
you said earlier i was used to be 325.
um so i started doing like personal
training stuff but my biggest thing is
like it's very expensive um so i wanted
to kind of come out here to like
help people that can't afford it and
stuff and basically do it on the side so
you and then i wanted to like there's a
lot of fat training no exactly it's a
big state there's a lot of porn you need
to go to san antonio there's a lot of
poor fat people here you're like exactly
that that's it seemed like the market
for it so if i could do free classes and
then uh i'd be doing like looking for
jobs doing like security working uh
doors that like you can meet a fat
barber yeah but you're from your hair
you're a sub
you're submissive you can't be a
security guard
if somebody like me can be like get out
of there this is just
that's my job though that's that's i
take that differently yeah it was his
job he's uh he's a good american if you
give him a job he'll do anything
yeah
but i mean i just because uh you don't
uh ask chrissy like chrissy is very
overpowering and plus she's confident
she's a comedian you know so she was
just on the ball uh if you had to ask
christy any questions and if you had to
be in charge of the date where would you
take her and what kind of questions
would you ask christy if you had to take
her on a date
um don't really uh if i were to take you
on a date i would probably
well since you said you like running i'd
probably go to like uh i don't know
there's that
i've been trying to get over to that
like the highest point in austin or
whatever that mountain or whatever
now
or whatever i'd probably go up there
do like lunch or something up there but
so romantic and remote
yeah oh yeah i was thinking
very smartly i wasn't thinking that at
all i was like how sweet we're gonna be
at the top of a mountain
kissing or whatever and like
nice i think you've already got this one
yeah christy share your location with me
just for safety progresses thank you
yeah i haven't been there
so you take her to a mountain
you'd run around a little bit and then
you'd have to talk to her eventually so
yeah when would you start the talk after
the run
i mean i wouldn't really plan on going
on a run if it was a day it would more
so maybe a stroll go up there and stuff
but and then
talk that once maybe you got it let's do
a little improv exercise you two are on
mount bonnell
going for a little stroll on your first
that you met on tinder and you don't
know that much about each other and uh
john you're leading and now you're
asking questions to christy and action
um so how do you like how
i don't even know
um
so how do you enjoy the walk
i mean it's like hard to keep up but
yeah it's fun
it's kind of cold
uh it's nice though
i
yeah i'm not too good at this clearly
john you're not getting laid tonight
show me your name
you [ __ ] up what what did you want to
know about christy i mean
not interested he doesn't care he's
nervous yeah he looks at me and he's
like uh
like i get it maybe he's just really
nervous when was the last time you went
on a date
two years ago probably oh wow i've been
in charleston and i haven't done
anything since there well thank you for
social distancing you're not vaccinated
exactly trying to do my part
did the last one go well or did it go
like this kind of
um it didn't go horrible
it wasn't yeah was she leading
like no i'm asking a lot of the
questions well it would the last date i
kind of knew the girl for a little bit
so it wasn't
it was your sister
i know how you do it in charleston
i'm from new york i'm from new york i
was born
so i was and yes upstate an hour north
but i worked down in all the boroughs as
an iron worker for like six years
beautiful nice
an iron worker yeah like all the
skyscrapers it was a 300-pound
ironworker yes pretty uh
wild sight to see at times so you were
sweatier than oh yeah do you weld
um somewhat i was more of a connector
yeah he welds legs shirt with his
questions
[Laughter]
yeah
no uh
that's fine that's christy where she
lives
ask her
ask her what she's doing what her
passion is
what motivates her
what are you most scared of and then
push me off the mountain or something
like that sorry that's not what i was
doing okay show me your nipple yeah
what does your penis smell like
so what are you passionate about what
are things that you have interest
besides in running
i'm passionate about like
um
social issues i guess okay
so vague
so liberal i think that less people
should be vaccinated
you should what
less people should be vaccinated
i mean choice
we're gonna get demonetized
this is going live on youtube oh
uh
i think that doctors are
are lying about a lot of things
dude everyone likes everything
is freaking out right she's
covering her ears
[Laughter]
she was like a nurse
or something
that wasn't a i don't think that's an
insult that's they're heroes yeah thank
you for your service i'm just saying you
might be a nurse are you a nurse
she's not a nurse nurses aren't infected
very cautious
she would never go on a date on mount
bonnell with the
january 6th interruptionist i'm
passionate like about a good nipple on a
guy because you know guys it's like hard
for them to keep up a good nipple it
like usually really gets messed up over
age and time oh my god
and dude you have to you have to like
live with that well he's a runner so his
nipples are probably really chafed they
could end up being chafed
um do you have a cream or a bomb for
that
no i tend to have nivea i haven't had
that problem yes you want nipples that
smell like molly's i'm gonna try to find
the one that doesn't smell like
grandmother
she smells good it's just like a memory
thing for me it's not it's not a bad
thing to smell like my grandma we all
want to smell like
molly's grandma that's the sponsor of
the show
moisturizer by molly's grandma she's
probably not vaccinated either
because she's dead yeah
and then she voted for but
she's not she's doing well
uh so any final parting words
if you are uh on a real date anything
that you would want christie to know
about you just to seal the deal john
um
oh on the mountain still
yeah sure
not real like uh
no
oh okay
so you're you think that you did good
enough you think you go oh no it
definitely didn't do any good well that
means that you're rejecting me you don't
want to even say goodbye oh no you're
hurting your feelings she's pretty yeah
oh no you're out you're gorgeous okay i
just did a bad job
yeah
i don't have any stds like i hey
wow why didn't you open with that like i
don't have any at all and i feel like a
lot of infection
that was a that was for a shark joke
okay okay just a bit yeah
okay chrissy vera and her
clean bill of health and john the guy
that runs they went on a date together
thank you so much for signing
up no women that signed up
[Music]
a human male
grant and dana
[Music]
hi dana how are you doing i am doing
very well how are you doing i'm awesome
i just got back from dallas i had a
wonderful time with family and friends
what did you do this weekend um
i got way too drunk uh
wasn't planning to but i did and i kind
of lost my voice same yeah yeah um we
need a voice crack counter on this date
real quick
uh we're just you know two oh that's bad
i would say two crackers but i was
looking i'm black i love it i love it
um so what did you do in dallas uh i
also drank uh quite a bit i got to see
some family my mom she's been a bit like
down on her luck recently she hurt her
foot so we got to hang out i got to
introduce some friends and then i
uh got to have a really good time with
an older friend of my mom's we uh we
partied at his place
oh okay because i was like to say if she
was an older woman i was like oh you
like cougars
yeah you know they need love too you
know
wait so how old are you i'm 25 about to
be 26 january 31st
well happy early birthday i'm going to
be 30. oh congratulations when you turn
30. uh may 6th so you know the day after
cinco de mayo and um i'm from san
antonio so sorry
i heard a san antonio joke and i was
like that's my city i'm sorry yeah you
were personally attacked there's a lot
of uh jokes made about dallas too and
how pretentious we are but uh i'm in
austin now so i'm getting better
no it's true i used to live in dallas
it's pretentious as [ __ ] oh really how
long
uh three years that's definitely enough
time to get a read on that place which
part and time
give it up for
[Music]
these two grant and dana
thank you so much for coming up
why do you think that a lot of women
haven't signed up today what do you
think uh you think i'm giving off too
much toxic masculinity
uh no no um a lot of women are actually
pretty shy about just randomly doing
things but i didn't know the bucket was
there to i know it was on the tickets
you know because i read
um but i just didn't know where to do it
there probably should have been a sign
oh that's a good note
we should put a sign up
this is it's not only a dating show it's
a show about how to run a show
it's like bar rescue but for shows
so grant uh you said that your mom broke
her foot have you uh ever thought about
giving her some moisturizer yeah you
know i think she deserves the best
moisturizer i'm looking for
recommendations i know nivea is great is
there one
even better i can get for her birthday
or something well thanks for asking uh
i'm actually sponsored by molly's
grandma's
moisturizer oh that's fine or whatever
i'll have to
get a nivea sponsorship
we totally should yeah i'm working on it
i'll support it yeah my mom will support
as well
we should uh lube up the uh old
ad revenue
stream the old grand prize
a fresh coat of paint on those cougars
in dallas stomp down on savings with
our advertisements anyways no one's
buying moisturizer from us
are there like healing qualities to your
your grandmother's lube or
it's called moisturizer her grandma does
not
she's still very wet down there grant
come on
you're very right
how's your mom doing
oh my mom's great like she just retired
i was in dallas for christmas and uh she
just was like i'm living my life and
then she tried to get me to do work like
gardening and build a fence because who
needs a man when you can have your
daughter build a fence
hell yeah i love that she thank you for
keeping the mexicans out
we really need to build that fence slash
wall she really believed in child labor
laws a lot
so you did a lot of the housework around
the house when you were growing up i was
black not cinderella pretty much
but yet you call yourself a cracker on
this very stage
oh i like crackers what can i say who
doesn't love a good cracker speaking of
crackers grant
hello
what uh how handy are you around the
house you think you'd be the the one
with the tool belt or would dana have to
uh you know screw in the light bulbs
yeah you know what um i was very
fortunate to grow up tall which also
means that i'm given the chores of
putting things on shelves and screwing
in light bulbs and
doing the work nobody wants to do so i
can always fill in the gaps for you
perfect can you wash dishes hell yeah i
just did today
he's experienced
he lives a life where he washes dishes
what a what a normal everyday man well
how relatable
thank you i i care about my family and i
try to help out i was washing them for
uh my my older
family he's like my godfather
yeah we partied in his house so i was
the least i could do
wait are you the mafia like godfather or
like
how did you this is live right okay this
is something white people do
they have so many fathers who just get
extra ones
i have two godfathers so that i guess
that puts me in two families of uh
you know waste management so luckily for
me i know my father but i only have one
wow
that's how you're supposed to do it
grant with your alternative lifestyle
yeah uh love my relationship with my
father we're more we're like drinking
buddies and we we have a good time but
you know mom is the one i really like
will go out and do stuff for
i would you say you're a mama's boy like
so oh yeah if your mom was here would
she be on the date with us would we need
a third chair
yeah actually i like to include her and
uh i probably i probably have a mistake
of introducing women to my mom too
quickly just because she's a really good
wing woman
that's bad yes
that's really bad you're [ __ ] up dude
going back to something you said that
you did chores i was a kid but i feel
like you definitely had a
like you were housekeeper you had a
housekeeper i did i'm making up for last
time what a rich [ __ ] this guy is
what a clown that's okay
so they look like a senator's son
thank you
she's like all marrying into a rich
cracker family adam
yeah
exactly multiple fathers godfathers more
family more presents for the holidays
mask lady what do you think about this
republican son
you think that
do you think that he uh votes correctly
i get to definitely
no he does i feel like it's like white
guilt you know what i mean
right
i feel like you're super liberal maybe
maybe she's not feeling well and she
just wants to mask up to help everyone
else in the room i'm talking about you
thanks for showing up anyways that's the
kind of spirit we need i'm sorry you're
sick just mess up and buy the ticket
so grant uh who did you vote for in the
last presidential election i voted for
that third party candidate joe jojo
no actually maybe that was the one
before
she loves him joe jorgensen
jojo jojo's bizarre adventure big fan
thank you for throwing your vote away
what
what made you luckily we didn't need you
grant we won by a large margin what did
you uh what did you like about jojo
i literally just didn't like either
other person enough to i had guilt you
know i was like i don't i don't feel
good this person is probably fine yeah
i'm sure they could handle it they they
got put on the ballot they're probably
capable right did you vote for harambe
before that
yeah i actually used to have a cutout of
harambe in my apartment
thank you for your service you're a real
model citizen
uh dana what did you think about the
last presidential election
um i was busy trying not to go insane
for so many different other reasons i
didn't kind of pay attention to anything
else
that's that makes sense wait what was
troubling you
oh
should i tell the truth or a lot um so i
used to work for
allegedly a company as a dating coach so
that drives me insane you'd be perfect
for the show can you give grant some
advice
yeah please so don't bring your mom uh
to like the second date got that
uh don't break your grandmother either
um
let's see so
your ouija board for that one but yeah
uh when you go to message a girl or guy
whatever you're into whatever um
don't say just hey at least try
actually that's like that's good advice
because uh yeah that's gone
you hear that
don't just take her to mount bonnell and
ask her how the walk is going
yeah and don't take women to remote
locations because we're all gonna think
you're going to murder us just like push
us right off the cliff and say bye
that's also good
take her to somewhere with a lot of
witnesses
yeah like the creek in the cave at 6 pm
put your name in a bucket and hopefully
he'll go on a date with the person you
arrive i have to say i love the
confidence for you to go up and do this
that speaks very highly of you as a
person oh thank you theater four years
fake it till you make it
every day of my life yes yes
let's do a little improv exercise let's
say that you are a volunteer at the
correct presidential candidates
volunteer office
and uh grant comes in with a little
clipboard and some talking points about
how we need to start polluting the ocean
or something
and action
hey so i'm i'm having some issues
deciding on who to vote for right now
and i'd love to hear your opinion on it
you seem like a very trustable person
well thank you so what are you having
issues with um what are your political
beliefs or what are some opinions that
you have like who do you think you align
with like do you have any social issues
or environmental issues
i definitely have issues but uh as far
as with candidates uh i i feel very
strongly one is
maybe not qualified maybe they're
talking out of their ass sometimes but
the other
they all they're
qualified also kind of talk out of their
ass so basically just feels like both
people are
incapable of communicating and making
decisions that are good so i don't know
third option c looks good right now oh
so you're indecisive okay yes so um how
about you just vote for a third party
like a libertarian
okay uh tell me a little bit about what
that means as like a what's a
libertarian not someone who works at a
library um but somebody oh damn i can't
even tell you [ __ ] and scene
wow that was getting really political
i thought it'd be uh more sexual you
know like maybe like put put your foot
in there or something uh you said that
you
didn't know you third party or whatever
do you uh do you often talk about
politics on dates or is that just when
i'm around i i try to avoid it as much
as possible uh but you you do kind of
get a sense of the person's political
beliefs just from regular conversation
nobody seems to lead that way somehow
so what is my political position would
you say um well i definitely
have seen you
on my computer also in person i think
you
definitely want to help people and do
the best for everybody
uh so you're all about you know a little
bit being a bit more liberal i guess is
that correct thanks man
that's what liberals are all about
helping people
and spreading out the uh wealth in a
redistribution camp
didn't you say you have like a lot of
money saved up that you're not touching
or sharing with anyone secret republican
yeah
yeah it's you can't have savings as a
liberal
yeah
give it away
yeah i'm actually a bit of a
conservative i uh i rule this show with
an iron fist
none of you are getting paid you don't
think you're financially conservative
maybe just
maybe you might be more in the middle
than you think you definitely love
people and helping but maybe you you
save a lot of money and you make good
yeah i do believe in helping people but
i'm also asian as [ __ ]
and i'm gonna buy up all the real estate
in austin so that i can use it as an
investment portfolio
but uh how long have you been in austin
dana
i moved here last year hey welcome to
austin
[Music]
i moved here last year too so i don't
know if i'm the best welcome committee
uh
what uh what made you move here um i got
a really good job so no one believes
that my job is a thing i'm a sleep
technician so i watch people sleep i'm
like santa hey with a god complex i feel
like john the guy before watches people
sleep also
[Laughter]
i don't think he gets paid for it though
wait you don't have sleep apnea do you
let me see your neck
he got a thickness maybe 300 pounds ago
he's hiding his neck with that beard he
doesn't want you to know oh man dudes
and their beards
yeah i i'm working on one but i love
that you you work with sleep i actually
talked about this on the way home like
my issues i told you i have some but
it's not anything
crazy grant you're putting us to sleep
so grant what do you do
uh i sell cyber security software to
fight
that guy over there the bear the bear
the big russian bear and all the
the other people securing our elections
so that you can vote for third-party
candidates that don't do anything
uh so you do cyber security you watch
people sleep
uh that's kind of cool you know uh what
do you what do you what have you found
out from watching people sleep has it
helped your sleep in any way
oh no i'm [ __ ] like
i can't sleep at all
i need a sleep study uh let's see i've
noticed i guess a lot of people who have
ptsd um have a lot of bad sleeping
issues and
a lot of people have sleep apnea and
they don't know it yeah so watching
people i watch people kind of low-key
die on a regular basis and i'm just like
oh
you're dipping
i hope i can give you air eventually
yeah that's great but do you know
anything about dreams because you're
doing sleep stuff is that part of it so
rim yeah i know a little bit about it
but like the thing is like i don't i
just see brain waves and i can see when
they go into a deeper sleep um a lot of
times some people it's kind of funny i
had hypothetically allegedly maybe a
patient go into their deep sleep and
then they started fishing and i was like
sir do you need help and he was like oh
i'm gonna catch a big fish and i was
like
oh he's just fishing
nice he's sleepwalking
uh no he has he's sleep fishing
parasomnia so he was acting out his
dreams nice
i have a question for you so
if i
i don't have terrible sleep apnea but
why do ever why does it seem like
everybody has it nowadays
uh so it can be environmental it can be
physical and now they're finding it can
be in family history i mean if you want
me to watch you sleep grant just let me
know i can i think we can arrange that
or something epigenetics does it have to
do with epigenetics
is that for diabetes or i didn't go to
college but i have a friend who's a
scientist so i like to throw out a word
yeah we all listen to joe rogan who can
so if uh you want to be fancy um there's
a fancy
polydipsia it's extreme thirst so you
can say all these boys are polydipsia
i've been obsessed with that word
all these thirsty men
trying to dip their [ __ ] into my
polyamorous relationships uh so
a lot of people have [ __ ] up sleep uh
grant
uh what what uh what what uh what do you
need help with you need help with your
crazy dreams yeah actually this is
something i want to get off my chest so
uh i i wonder if it's a scientific or a
spiritual thing right it's uh
sometimes i i don't have sleep paralysis
but i wake up and i see like a mirage of
something on the wall kind of like a
shadow
and i'm awake and aware but i'm so
convinced it's real that i kind of look
talk to it sometimes that's called a
team analysis
but i can i get up like i'm moving but
i'm stuck in this like mirage where
there literally is sleep paralysis and
i'm not a sleep technician i just love
my brows i mean i was going to say like
if he tells me he has sex samia i'm like
i don't know what to do with that
maybe you do so what is a cure for sleep
paralysis
oh there's no care you just see demons
and we just move about the day
just gonna have to get over it grant
it's not a big deal walk it off
wait do you work with anyone who has uh
like night terrors where they start
screaming in their sleep yeah um i have
seen so i used to work do pediatrics and
also adults and geriatic whatever um all
the ages um so
i've seen people have like
besides sleep apnea night terrors
i've also seen people like sleepwalk
sleep it's funny until kids start
giggling at two or three in the morning
and they're just like what the [ __ ] they
laughing about terrifying yeah that's
terrifying wait one more question i have
no
questions people have told me i moan in
my sleep this is not a joke is is that
normal oh i've had people moan in their
sleep um the funnest thing i think i've
seen is someone with sex omnia it's a
little
yeah the guy the person didn't know that
uh they would try to [ __ ] their wife in
the middle of the night
yeah
that's when you put a dude
you put a dude in her bed and see if he
still does the same thing
i don't know
yeah
let's bring over one of your patients we
want to have a little maybe slap some
nivea on him so that he smells like a
grandma
no why nivea there's so many other
better lotions like what coconut well i
mean coconut oil is great but you also
have coconut no but we're talking brands
you know what i mean
[Music]
aquaphor but that's a little too sticky
for a hand job
going back to his hand job we're not
talking about the sleep patient
yeah maybe you could uh slap some uh
moisturizer on these sleep paralysis
patients you know
they wake up
so the sex omni is probably the most
interesting to you of all these
different things
i mean
i think it was to you
you seemed the most interested in this
like oh i can use that as an excuse the
next great value
i'm sorry i suffer from touched out if i
have that too
yeah how do you test that that seems so
strange to like how do you start they'd
like record it and tell you honestly
what happened or did someone watch or
what
no so all
patients list down their like medical
reasons and needs and i've only had two
or three who that happened to but
sometimes it's trauma but i don't know
if you want to joke about sexual trauma
um
yes let's go down that rabbit hole
perfect grant any uh sexual
no uh drama because he she said that uh
it's usually because of trauma so maybe
something happened to you like you
you're seeing [ __ ] on the wall yeah uh
as far as like demons or shadow people
and all that stuff uh i don't know maybe
i just consumed too much like negative
media like watch too many cartoons
that's what mom always would blame you
know
um grant i feel like you remember the
taste of your mom's breast milk is that
true
probably
uh
i
no comment
give it up for grant and dana
they went on a date together
[Music]
what a beautiful couple
please come back
uh
[Music]
hey uh you guys want to go on a date
[Music]
you guys can go up separately
[Music]
i usually
[Music]
[Music]
catalina catalina going on a date with
justin lopez
that's him right there i know it
come on justin
you signed up
your name's in the bucket the bucket
must be obeyed
[Music]
just come up here and make fun of
us nerds
[Music]
justin lopez is not coming up
i think he has a gun
let's uh let's move on
garrett
going on a date with catalina
[Music]
catalina and gareth give it up for them
one more time all right thank y'all
thank you all
so my idea the perfect date is uh just
shooting up some heroin
[ __ ] in public and then passing out
behind the dumpster you with me on this
one or what you did not go to my sober
high school oh [ __ ] a sober high school
what the [ __ ] is that dude
what is this so wait no what is this so
legitimately i have no idea what you're
talking about i've been high for 10
years
what is a sober high school where you
have to you have to be sober
what the how do they force that how do
they force them
wait why do they make you go to aaa if
you're not an alcoholic that doesn't
seem to make sense that's you're
literally stepping over all of the steps
there
to go
not everyone is an alcohol you can be an
addict and alcohol you can have eating
disorder this is true um
code dependency yeah this is very true
well you're a very pretty lady do you
have any codependencies
um i have a lot of equipment
duh um so like last night i uh went out
with a girl who was my ex-girlfriend i
made out with her
and uh
you know i want to be truthful here guys
okay i'm not
this is who
give it up for gareth and catalina
gareth was about to tell a really
problematic story yeah it was um
on this day
oh okay so uh catalina you went to a
sober high school
i did so did this lady over here so you
all went to like the opposite of
euphoria yeah i haven't seen it but
astro world baby
i actually got hbo max like last night
to watch it
well yeah but then i started watching
the sex lives of um college girls mindy
kaling i know i i love the the cute
so you went to the lamest high school
ever
we didn't have homework
you didn't have homework
dude that's pretty cool i'll go to that
high school the homework was just don't
[ __ ] your life up
right
yeah we all went to rehab
eating disorder
places
anyway well enough about me so what did
you if you had a party at your sober
high school oh we had sprom
sober prom sober problem yeah baby did
you guys like bob for apples
and stuff i wish
did you vote for trump danced
i think are you a troll
does sobriety make you vote for trump or
you're [ __ ] the data yeah i know come
on wait do you go into like iss or
something if you relapse no we had like
there was like separate like there was
like the sober high school but then
there was
um like pre-sober what it's
[Music]
gareth i was worried at first you
weren't being vulnerable and she was you
were came into it joking but then you
kind of came around i liked that you
started being like interested in what
she was saying i am i'm very interested
in everybody i think you put up a little
bit of a front and i think you should be
more vulnerable okay i'll tell you
everything about me not right now oh god
please don't wait
wait you okay so i have a very dry venus
not penis venus the elbow i was in third
grade i know what a wenis is okay cool
do you have any moisturizer on you by
chance
questions no stop stop yeah
okay uh so catalina
you weren't allowed to do drugs in the
high school but were you allowed to bone
[ __ ] you yeah that's what i'm saying if
you don't do drugs
you know you're [ __ ] yeah
you need to drink like um some apg drink
red wine you know the energy drink
red lime you've never heard of red lion
no no wait where are you from i'm from
houston oh okay h town i love houston so
thanks for the bike he's also from
houston right are you i am
i grew up off of bunker hill
okay memorial memorial district area
that's correct yeah absolutely cypress
hill yeah what's up
yeah
do you uh do you like uh toyota cars by
chance
if it's like um the forerunner oh yeah
oh you're a foreigner i do but
is it lifted you probably uh no have you
ever heard of fred haas toyota world
budget i'm familiar with this this is my
family that's why i will you have gareth
you're rich
that is not my empire
i am rich adjacent
[Music]
gareth you [ __ ] it up white men care a
lot about money i don't know if you knew
that or not uh we're all very empty
inside i do love capitalism this is a
thing
you capitalist gareth you're [ __ ] it
up again yeah it's fine so
let's get the feedback a little down
uh so
he worked his uh grandfather is fred
haas of hospital
if you could uh buy any toyota if you
could get any toyota for free from
gareth which which
only four runners
so she's into suvs
that's a solid call
so let's do an improv exercise you go
into a fred haas dealership and there is
gareth fisk a guy that you went on a
date with oh hello and now you're trying
to get a car for free and you know he
can do it
in action
the cleavage is a very good call
hey buddy hey
how's it going
they got got any uh heroin
no
we got any like
under 60 000 miles
four runners
lifted all black out
any
wait keep rubbing my shoulder hold on
that felt really good yeah did you
forget what i was talking about yeah
yeah scene okay
give it up for that sexual assault we
just saw
whoa
no
gareth was at a
car dealership and a massage parlor
combined into one
speaking of which uh catalina what are
what are you racially you're sort of
racially ambiguous
what do you think
asian okay but what kind of asian
north
um i would say maybe filipina or maybe
canadian native canadian or
i can see that no i'm half thai my mom's
from thailand half thai and half boring
actually yes you're white half white
yeah okay yeah if we got married could
you adopt communism as your
gareth please stop trying to make it
political
you're really making my dick soft
do i make your dick hard hans wait hold
on
gareth so what are you uh
what what have you have you ever used
your connection to fred haas for
anything like productive no uh i
actually tried to as much as possible
not ask for anything because that's the
way to do it i think if you uh don't ask
for anything then you give given things
eventually that's how it usually goes
you usually don't want to uh [ __ ] around
you know and do comedy because my uncle
doesn't like that but uh hey here we are
this is where we are as life uncle
doesn't like that you're running around
sharing this family business no dude
he's like i'm not following you what's
something that your uncle would not want
you to say on live youtube right now
uh
i don't think i should say it
no thanks uh well hondas are secretly
better i like trust funds um what what
what a boring trust function dude [ __ ]
you hans why are you calling everybody
boring all right man why don't you tell
us more about sharing any secrets you're
not getting free cars
i can share secrets do you want me to
share secrets yes okay i'm gonna share
secrets right now
uh my penis is about five and a half
inches flaccid
uh
fred haas is disappointed
uh
i have never been with a black woman
before
um what else is new uh
let's see here um i have a a solid
income however
uh i do have sex insomnia whatever what
was that thing she was talking about do
you want to go on a [ __ ] other man in
a place let's get another man up here
i uh i got to be the host
yeah you can get another one
give me the contract
sure i heard catalina's dad is mattress
mac how do you feel about that
dude gallery furniture saves you money
today that's what i think about that
it's a thing
marvin zindler you can put the mattress
in the car and live in inside your car
it's hard
fence out of my kia
he needs to get me a
forerunner oh okay i like the [ __ ]
bed though
i don't like [ __ ] in four runners
like that's it's hard to fly it's hard
to maneuver in a car i just want to be
happy to [ __ ]
oh no totally
no i'm there but i like to be
comfortable nonetheless like i have i
need to maneuver [ __ ] me in the
forerunner
depending gareth
you're not going to [ __ ] me in the
forerunner
he only [ __ ] people who are uh
heirs to conglomerates
he's a
uh no no no no no no no no that's not it
that's not it at all i'm just very vain
um
i like uh i like uh men that's the thing
i uh
give it up for gareth bye guys
[Music]
friends with catalina
[Applause]
[Music]
man i'm in love with this woman dude
i was over there motorboating that son
of a [ __ ] earlier man
holy [ __ ] i love her let's go on a date
where are we at where what's the setup
what's the setup what is it italian
restaurant
i didn't know you like spaghetti
i love spaghetti
what's up baby
holy [ __ ] i haven't seen you in 30
minutes
longest 30 minutes of my life right here
dude
i love you
sorry i'm a terrible
do
dater
go on tinder
tinder what the [ __ ] is that man i don't
even understand how that works man this
guy knows though hey watch out watch out
with this
i love this guy dude but
yeah yeah
i don't do gender sorry i one on one
like that's how we met man we met at the
bar man earlier i know because i was in
distress
like in distress me myself oh [ __ ] i'm
stressed out whenever i meet people man
but how do you like do it
i'm all kind of stressed right now man
you asking me this kind of question what
do you mean now i'm so confused what do
you mean say that again like how do you
normally meet woman
ah man it's been a while dude uh
normally it's uh just like hey what's up
and time
give it up for nikita kleistov
aka pasha and catalina give it up for
them
give them a little clapper
god damn it i'm terrible
i feel like i just had an aneurysm i
don't know what just happened i have no
idea i think i feel like
uh yeah she lost me she lost me hello
you know what i mean
who the [ __ ] are you
i love it dude oh we're on youtube right
now this is [ __ ] safe are you a
character from a will ferrell can i put
my glasses on
no where are you from
russia originally but oklahoma city guys
oh my god
i didn't know they made rednecks in
russia
russian redneck you ever met one
take a picture
i'll be there
i feel like you're the after effect of
like chernobyl
i was actually there
unfortunately i'm the only
that makes survivor i believe you
probably
radiated russian is just a uh drunk
oklahoman
uh
it's interesting because the top of your
head is thinner than the bottom of your
head
it gets wider as you go
further down as it goes down dude yes i
know does that help you drink more vodka
do you chase the vodka with bud light
beers on him or borscht
boris hell yeah there you go mama i love
it
okay you're trying to sell my man i feel
like i'm cheating on my date right now
i'm cheating on my day right now we
could
so uh where would you guys go on a date
together this week absolutely italian
places for sure dude she looks like it
she would enjoy that
maybe would you like to eat pasta with
this russian redneck
some meatballs
some meatballs in there no
okay that's terrible that's terrible i'm
sorry i'm terrible mind your man we're
probably going to mexican restaurant or
tex-mex you know what i mean i bet you
make the worst country songs ever me
russian it's like a tetra song with your
voice on it really it's pretty good
right garth brooks [ __ ] right i don't
know you got the voice for it for sure
garth brooks is good
so uh
what what's your dating situation you
brought a date with you tonight or hell
yeah man my brother man we're gay you're
brother
no i'm kidding you really are from
oklahoma we brought arkansas and
brotherhood in here no i'm kidding he's
married he's a good kid
for a
moment were in the kkk for a second i'm
single in the brotherhood wait how old
are you
too old
just answer the questions
oh my goodness this is like a police
officer wait wait a minute i need some
what are you a copy 37.
he's always suspicious of the kgb i
always got to watch out man especially
you
catalina
catalina uh what did you think about
this uh pasha dude and uh what would you
say to him if you met him at a bar i
love you well i did meet him at a bar
outside
absolutely not
i met him outside he seemed like a
really nice man
i think he just has a little bit nervous
you have very poor taste in men
this guy
is gonna leave you in about two months
uh so what is your dating history how
many times have you been divorced pasha
zero zero wow that's both unlikely in uh
oklahoma and russia
how many uh hand drops have you paid for
uh zero
okay okay okay all right i'm being
honest
i just paid her so don't bring that up
first time
this is some tailgate humor right here
she didn't accept credit cards
no checks
if you were gonna take her on a real
date where'd you take or like win stars
like you mean like casino yeah you're
probable
you mean never win like norman kind of
stuff no yeah i don't know probably i've
never met a guy that lost both world war
ii and uh
i should have said world war one
i don't know where we're at right thank
you for uh defeating the nazis for us
you're welcome and also [ __ ] you for
slavery
what the [ __ ]
how do you feel about jews
i love them
what if they're gay
i love them still
ah whatever
what do you mean like big-nosed gay
people like that's cool as hell dude
i'm so confused that's my family
i love you
was that your brother i love him
uh so where what what is your biggest
weakness
uh being on stage guys what's up
you're doing a great job man
you're a character you're weird as [ __ ]
i [ __ ] love it dude i'm not scared to
be on stage nothing scares me catalina
what is your biggest weakness
me
weakness what a [ __ ]
creepy uncle
this guy is not invited to family reads
37
you are not 37 there's no way
no i'm [ __ ] like 74 man
how old do i look
i'm getting like seven different ages
from you
like that's the vibe yeah like
for every age you gotta explain why so
start for the first
there's a maturity of what we say that's
not how the show works
yeah we are the ones in power we're like
putin here oh oh my goodness holy [ __ ]
here let me have my phone call calendar
make a buckle we're gonna ride of course
yeah
you're in a corn do you want to take off
your shirt right now [ __ ] no dude you
kidding me
i'm here to make out not take my shirt
off
what about a nip slip
yeah show us your nipple what's a man
slip is that what that is
oh my
goodness we're gonna guess pink or brown
oh
five bucks guys three five bucks right
here on the table five bucks i'm gonna
say well pink he said pink
he's got five on it anyone got brown
nobody else anyone else
to go for brown i love that uh hairy or
non-hairy nipple let's do this
[Music]
nipple now hairy or non-hairy
say hairy nipple baby ah
that's a pink one [ __ ] i got a
six-pack hey behind each cake there's a
six-pack
mine are like see-through so
son of a [ __ ]
you're a very interesting person
catalina uh
how are you dating history like have you
ever dated someone that was uh as
douchey as this guy
he's not douchey though
oh then he she definitely has
how many guns do you own
uh there's two of them right here pound
this one and they found this one and
there's two
sorry no safeties
[Music]
giving 68 years old right yes wait a
minute there's a third gun coming up
it's a joke okay all right calm down
this guy has the same humor as
yeah pro shop
i am that guy
i i literally go hunt deer off the boat
that's what i do for a living
i go buy a boat just so i can go hunt
deers
on the side of the river man
do you know what deer are
you you hunt aquatic deer
um catalina what are you have you ever
been hunting
she's coming
[Music]
this is our first date for christ's sake
so uh if you two were to go out into the
wild
uh what would you what would you what
was the first thing that you guys would
do together you need a really nice cabin
like glamping
wow
it's the first date just very difficult
what do you want to know though
that's absolutely something i want you
to know
yes absolutely uh what's that
what uh
where would you go camping
i do
you asked me if i had a flat driveway i
said yes
[Music]
we're on a first date for christ's sake
why would you share that with me how do
you feel about your date hitting on me
right why would you share that with me i
didn't know you're like
shelter do you feel emasculated by this
tiny little soy boy stealing your date
my balls are moving right now this is
weird
they're doing this right now i ain't
[ __ ] you it's weird
i feel like i'm on the couch watching
porn
like asian porn like white screen [ __ ]
i love you guys
i love you too what kind of porn do you
watch
[ __ ] only you dude you wouldn't know
humsborn man band stuff a lot of step
sisters step brother porn
a lot of outdoor winter porn
we make porn dude so i don't watch porn
dude it's weird
give it up for uh pasha and catalina
another day together
[Music]
uh we have one we have no more men's
name in here any man want to go on a
date
[Music]
manly man
wants to
get laid
brad do you want to go on a date
red one
[Music]
she wants to go on a date with brad
man
he's been back he's been back five times
nice to meet you i am happy to black
girls yeah
he's down with the swirl [ __ ] yeah okay
i'm brad i'm jasmine nice to meet you
guys you know why a little ghetto you
know just a little spicy
oh dumb okay
where are you from jasmine i'm from
texas where in texas um so i grew up in
um
colleen colleen okay
you'll see me all right
the ghetto a little bit you know um i
moved around i was married okay to a
military man oh i've been divorced for
almost three years all right cool this
will work this time yeah yeah yeah um
so we lived in colorado springs for
three years and then
and then upstate new york for two cool i
lived in new york for a while oh yeah
what part uh new york city and harvard
i was like 30 minutes from the canadian
border
[ __ ] that [ __ ] okay
it's eight inches of snow we're on lake
we're literally on lake ontario
literally so eight inches is too much
right i agree
it depends on what ages we're talking
about oh
[Laughter]
what ages are we talking about of snow
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah snow yeah
that's too much eight inches of white
just like far too much i agree 100
and time give it up for brad and jasmine
with the y
and a c n c
i think that last little uh conversation
he had was about cocaine i think they
just made a cocaine deal in front of us
you guys do cocaine jazz do you do
cocaine no but i smoke a lot of [ __ ]
weed a lot oh yeah hell yeah yeah i love
weed i'm actually upstanding for a month
i just joined a friend in a month long
but i would love to join you in a month
once a week yeah let's smoke definitely
i haven't got a ride you smoke sativa
um
either hybrid sativas indicas i'm down
with it
she's uh buy marijuana
[Music]
like a really big accomplishment
oh god i don't know because i usually
once i'm high i get the munchies and
then i'm out like done for done for the
count you should go take a sleep
paralysis
dana's actually my i came with dana so
that's awesome
uh brad on the date you asked if
colorado springs is in colorado
i'm
[Music]
we'll work on it where in colorado is
colorado springs um it's about an hour
from denver i don't know if it's north
or south to be honest
is it south okay i have no idea i love
it out there
i really do but it's just not somewhere
i would want to live it's just too um
you guys were talking about how
california people are from people from
colorado and new york are coming to
texas too so
stay your asses back where you guys are
from don't come here okay but we're
gonna build a fence but why is it
because they're like really late i don't
think people look at the well i don't
think people look at the economy in the
logic sense of it once you move to these
places and these people are coming from
here our economy is going to go up too
you know what i mean so
i mean austin's already the cost of
living is already expensive as it is so
these people who move here it's only
going to increase the cost of living and
then taxes who knows the state taxes
will be
at the end of the day in favor of
deporting californians in college [ __ ]
yeah
i'm sorry are you trying to build the
wall here no i wouldn't just austin no
no no no no no
let's just uh give everyone guns and
tell them we're not vaccinated and then
they'll
[Music]
it's a medical thing because you're not
supposed to feel anything about it
you're supposed to [ __ ] do it go with
it whatever whatever your doctor says
are you a doctor no um i work in
administration i do a little of
everything i do however have my degree
in biology so nice administration makes
good money it it is it's um i do well
for myself i guess
would you like to uh be a sugar mama to
brad
um i'm more looking for a sugar daddy
why would you be looking for that you
have a lot of money i'm no no i'm not
i spend a lot of money though
what do you spend it on clothes cheers
i have my coochie pierced too so there
you go
a little stimulation
oh yeah we're on the coochie
my clitoris is pierced wow
i thought about getting the hood part i
want to get that next actually i want to
get my hood done i don't think i shower
enough
that's just honestly i love your honesty
i'm here for it
you're gonna just have like a studded
[ __ ]
it's gonna be like a leg i really do
want my hood that's what i wanted
originally but the lady just pierced my
clay so i was like whatever i'm down
with wait you went in for a hood
piercing and she pierced my [ __ ] yeah
i think you can see that it doesn't hurt
though it didn't hurt so and i don't
take i don't have a high pain tolerance
so i don't know how i did it
that's that's that's illegal
someone just assaulted you
uh so does that help the sensation yeah
so mine is
it's very sensitive now since i've had
it yeah i'd imagine um i mean it was but
it just like times ten now with the
piercing
wow so it's like uh if if you have a
vibrator does it like like make a weird
noise
that was a brian question that is
a very valid question yeah yeah it is
valid yeah no but no i don't it doesn't
make a weird noise nice how do you how
do you feel about
how do you feel about is it something
that's easy for you to take in and out
the piercing yeah i mean yeah it's not
hard okay cool you know just got to
reach down there and unhook it
so otherwise that would have been a deal
breaker for me i've had experience with
it it's bad i have like something yeah
no it's yeah i've had a great experience
with it so
it's gonna get his mouth off of [ __ ]
for his whole junior year very
uncoordinated too so i need all the help
i can get but like if a guy goes down on
you does it taste like nickels
i hope not i always think about that and
i hope not i don't think so i've never
heard you should do it if it does just
get a new pair start a poll right like
yeah does my [ __ ] taste like an
anonymous one because like
they're probably put up with it and do
it again but they don't want to yeah
anonymous poll on like your instagram
story yeah yeah
just like if you've eaten it tell me
does it taste like nickels
pennies
have you ever like thought of putting
any cool piercings on it like if you're
in the mood for like little little fish
no god no i didn't know like a belly
button ring one that like says like
[ __ ]
i would i would go with i would go with
that yeah or like a feather you know
oh drink catcher
brad you have no excuse for not being
able to find the [ __ ] tonight that's how
i do have yeah just bring a flashlight
on a magnet
what are those little detectors that
that security guards have and it will or
like on the beach or you're like so what
do you say
when you uh go through security or metal
detection
i've never i mean i go through tsa all i
mean i like to travel so i go through
tsa i don't think i've ever
i don't
know
i hope no terrorists are listening
i recently just got stopped at tsa
because i had like a really
large
pointy glass dildo in my carry-on and
they stopped me and they were like what
is this and i was like
it's a
big glass dildo
and he was just like
i'm gonna take your word for it
[Laughter]
so
awesome maybe uh
jasmine could
put it on as like a piercing
uh is it like a iud slash pearson can
you get one of those combo i don't i
don't know how that works i don't know
let's put some copper in there
probably
that's awesome yeah that clip piercing
is really really dope so funny snag it's
actually no
oh i lied on my loofah oh
that was hard i i was almost in tears
trying to unhook it unravel it from the
piercings
maybe just use your hand for the vagina
area
but the fun fact
my um
the only reason why i got it pierce is
because my mom told me to get it she was
like you should do it because i wanted
to get my nipples redone this is an
episode
sisterhood of the traveling pants
my yeah goes just get your coochie she's
like it doesn't hurt so like a month
later i got my coochie for you girls my
yeah my best friend's mom she went with
her mom to go get it she watched her mom
oh really
yeah which that's cool
i'm pretty close with my mom so i tell
her everything almost everything's she's
like my best friend though
i have like i have a good relationship
with my parents your family is really
important to me yeah yeah my parents are
still married and you know yeah
let's not brag uh i know i'm sad
this is 2022.
i'm an orphan will she adopt
probably she's they're really kind
will she pay for me to get my [ __ ]
pierced she probably would
i will pay for you to get your [ __ ]
pierced if you apply with jasmine's mom
she'll sponsor you to uh
just holler at me just holler at me
scissors let me know
you can click piercings together
oh yeah
where did you go to get your hood
pierced i was actually living in upstate
new york at the time so i went to this
with john
john yeah probably he was there
was there running around just
like i can't believe what i saw this is
she just got her [ __ ] pierced what were
you in the adirondacks no i was world
upstate so like um watertown carthage i
was like an hour from syracuse
okay right up there i lost my virginity
and
i was literally 30 minutes from the
canadian border
oh yeah yeah yeah that border does not
play no but it's it was worth it because
you get to go to like toronto ontario
montreal did you go to canada's
wonderland the theme park no i didn't is
it i'm gonna have to think about that
next time
i like
canada yeah it's the people are nice
like she wants to live in canada
yeah comedy i don't know i think that's
maybe too literal for her
she's got everything pierced uh
what did you uh what did you think about
the clip here have you ever been with a
woman that had a [ __ ] pierced i have uh
yes
and uh yeah a bad experience
it was it was my first time um oh you're
like does everyone have this no it was
really exciting at first but it was uh
i was like wow i've never seen this
before only in porn
um
i didn't notice any like experience on
my end uh
other than like i found eating out uh to
be incredibly difficult like i didn't
like it so eventually
she took it out because but answer the
question nickels or nah
once a month no i don't does it taste
like nickels no no absolutely i wouldn't
think so i think if you click and clean
mine so anytime
that's more like a penny taste anyways
get your coins dimes
[Music]
i'm not down for cheesecakes or anything
like that on like
cheesecake i don't do sex on my period
absolutely not what does cheesecake mean
because you know like a regular
cheesecake the red
oh like a new yeah
i see what you're saying okay
yeah i'm not down with that absolutely
not the cream pie but with the red swirl
okay that's gross i think it's called
cheesecake isn't it
well yeah
you're right i'm wrong i don't know what
she's taking cheesecake with a fork in
it
that's her piercing you guys should go
to cheesecake factory
yeah they're okay the cheesecake is good
but the food is not that gross oh girl
you're ordering the really i don't i
always get the pastas all kinds of
pastas from there and i'm not okay with
it every time i need to go with pasha to
olive garden chipotle pasta is good
there
oh i have to consider it it's good and
the louisiana pasta is good
okay i always get the chicken alfredo
from there because how can you [ __ ] up
chicken alfredo we're now sponsored
so many of their menus i steal them and
collect them oh good for getting like
books
a whole live stream well okay so i like
to still like when you go to like texas
roadhou when you go to restaurants they
give you those little small dishes
i like to take those and my mom has a
cabinet like for sauce yeah my mom yes
my mom has a cabinet full because i just
take them in my to-go box i'm like okay
so i'm a sauce girl yeah me too you love
doing dishes yeah i do where do you
store dirty dishes if you're trying to
steal them
you put it in your to-go box and then
you go home and wash it
yes
this is why all the restaurants in
america are failing right now
because of me i steal dishes they have
no plates
i don't know if i would do pla i haven't
done plates i have taken some saucers
before though you know like the little
small plates i've taken those
forks knives you know
what i just take it like i don't know
what's wrong with me you're getting like
two dollars i'm not a calypso i swear oh
that's cool sounds like klepto i'm not a
club
it's just like spontaneous brad have you
ever stealing stolen anything
uh
hearts no hearts i felt really bad about
when i was a little kid i stole a
handful of like fake snow from a store i
thought it was really cool and it was
like a broken bag and i felt so bad
about it my dad looked at me and he was
like you just stole that and i felt so
bad i cried about it for like a week oh
no it's a display right
no no it was like a bag of fake snow
that was like busted open i was like oh
this is so cool and you just took your
you just took that are you talking about
cocaine again
that's all i talk no um
gangsta okay oh yeah
oh yeah no no no
i don't i don't think that's as ghetto
as colleen is
she's from colleen
kill city you know
two five four do you think i'd do well
there
as a jew
yeah i mean just stay in your lane i
guess i don't know your lane
jews
i honestly i don't like i grew up
actually in a nicer area of colleen
which you know my parents they bought
land they bought they built a house out
there so i didn't live in the ghetto or
anything but it's i when i moved back to
texas after my divorce i moved back to
colleen and i was like oh i need to get
the [ __ ] out because i well i was
commuting to
i was commuting to work from um to
austin all the time and it was over an
hour drive just to get to work from
colleen so but it's um it's pretty bad
out there
one bedroom in austin split the rent
i'm looking for a spot i yeah i pay 1200
just for a one bedroom she already has
all the plates yeah hell yeah and
utilities water not included so
what what
it's expensive
no
you know most places have water included
i don't have water included they
probably cover a different utility yeah
usually they pick one i think luckily
your [ __ ] gets so wet from having an
extra sensitivity i might not need to
brad can just open his mouth between
your legs i'm just the squirting machine
i guess
brad has to like get pails of water from
your [ __ ] and just bring it to the
kitchen
to boil for pasta
this will be
factory good you like it homemade
water it starts [ __ ] juice is just the
razzle dazzle on top of it i guess you
know it's not just your average wet ass
[ __ ]
thief
yeah
and i'm not saying that because brad's
uh italian
um
[ __ ] wet us [ __ ] more like
holy ass [ __ ]
hop
[ __ ] with a hole in it hop two
technically
how big is your [ __ ] well when you
appear when they pierce it they go
through it twice they have to pierce it
through it twice
yeah they go through it two times they
like sew it it's like almost like you
know how a belly button is pierced
that's how your clay is you just mean
exit yeah into an exit yeah okay i get
in your piercings
people don't have that because some
people have it i was just gonna put one
hole in when i did it but okay yeah i
don't have a hoop i have like a little
barbell
okay yeah okay i got you well that was
the date with brad and jasmine thank you
so much for coming out
that was super interesting
and a little disturbing
what did you think about that date
that was my favorite one
it was an extreme name
[Music]
but they were bold and they owned it
even like brad owens not knowing
colorado
was a pretty springs mistake
i feel like brad would be a kind of guy
that would be into piercings he looks
sort of like he likes pain he looks like
he's skateboards he is like alt he has
an alternative look to him yeah i think
they are they're a good couple
but you
yeah yeah it's got real my chemical
romance energy yes
uh give it up for all the dates you saw
tonight thank you guys so much this is
molly vivint you can follow her on
instagram how did i get so sexy uh
anything else you want to plug
um i have a new kill tony coming out
check her out on tony next monday thank
you guys so much
you